Magnus Carlsen just played what is
likely his last classical chess game as
world champion Magnus became Champion 10
years ago in 2013 after defeating
vishwanathan Anand Magnus first reached
the number one world ranking in January
of 2010 and he has been the sole holder
of that position from July of 2011 to
the present day in his time as world
champion Magnus has attained a peak
classical chess rating of 2882 the
highest ever Magnus also went on a
125-game undefeated streak another world
record though Magnus has chosen not to
defend his title he is still the best
player in the world and is committed to
continuing his dominance in the Chess
World and Blitz rapid online and
over-the-board tournaments just not in
the classical World Championship
still for many the world championship
holds a special Mystique which is why it
is Bittersweet that